hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american psychological
thriller film called sightless
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the film starts with a young girl who is
depressed and alone
she then decides to jump off of her
apartment balcony
the scene shifts to a month earlier
showing that same young woman named
helen
helen used to be a famous violinist one
night
she is brutally attacked in a car parked
by an unknown attacker
wearing a gas mask spraying chemicals on
her eyes
she is then immediately brought to a
hospital and wakes up on a hospital bed
with both of her eyes covered in
bandages soon a nurse named omar comes
to take the bandages
off as the bandages are taken off she
realizes she can't see anything
shortly after a doctor named katsuro
enters her room
he explains that the chemicals she was
exposed to left her optic nerve intact
but seared in simple terms the damage is
irreversible
and she is now completely blind having
lost her eyesight forever
ellen is distraught and only reluctantly
accepts her altered situation
then a detective named bryce comes and
asks her questions about the incident
she explains to detective bryce what she
knows
a few moments later ellen talks to her
brother who's in tokyo
on the phone he tells her he has
organized a hidden apartment close to
the city center for her to live in
and a caretaker who specializes in
helping people like her who are
adjusting to their new lifestyle
the next day ellen wakes up in her new
apartment and meets her new caretaker
clayton however she has no memory of the
trip home from the hospital
which clayton explains away by saying
that the drugs she is on our powerful
clayton tells her that he is a
professional caretaker and he will
assist ellen in her daily activities
and slowly assist her transition as a
blind person
he will come to her place every day at
11am and leaves at 2pm
he adds that she is now in her new
apartment on the ninth floor of the
building
and he explains the layout of the
apartment to ellen after clayton leaves
ellen tries to call her friend sasha and
her brother
but both of them do not pick up her
calls she feels so empty as she has
neither family nor
friends to talk to during this difficult
period the next day
clayton brings ellen a pet budgie in a
cage she asks him what color it is
clayton tells her it's baby blue
afterward ellen notices that when she
stands next to one of her windows
she can hear the noise from the busy
street below but when she stands near
another window she can't hear anything
clayton explains that the glass there is
thicker so she won't be able to hear
anything
they both then talk to each other about
their lives slowly forming a close bond
between them
ellen then asks permission to touch
clayton's face to which he agrees
that night ellen hears a woman crying
while being abused by someone
she initially believes the woman is in
her apartment but it turns out that the
crying sound comes through the vent
the next day she decides to invite her
neighbor for tea
so she walks out into the hallway and
leaves a post-it note on the door of the
apartment next door
asking the woman to join her for tea
that night
the woman named lana knocks on ellen's
door and comes in for tea
she acts strange though she knows ellen
used to be a violinist and lost her
sight
she seems to know a lot about ellen even
though they just met
ellen touches her face and to her
surprise she feels a fresh scar on
lana's face
lana reacts by warning her not to trust
anyone and she runs out of the apartment
ellen becomes convinced that lana's
husband is being physically abusive to
lana
so ellen reaches out to detective bryce
telling him about the abuse her neighbor
is getting from her husband
detective bryce sends over officer
nieman to talk to her neighbor and make
sure
everything is all right later he
confirmed she is okay and the scar was
just a birthmark
the next morning she notices a strange
thing about the place
she explains to clayton that a car alarm
goes off every other day at precisely
11am
the time clayton arrives at her place
daily the same car
same alarm same time clayton dismisses
the oddities
and tells ellen that it is a big city
it's got lots of alarms
later that night ellen thinks lana comes
into the apartment again
however when she touches her shoulder it
turns out to be lana's abusive husband
he threatens her to leave his wife alone
and stop being paranoid
feeling threatened ellen immediately
asks clayton to come to her place
clayton arrives and comforts her at that
time clayton tells her that he has
feelings towards her
however ellen rejects the interest by
stating that she needs a caretaker more
than a boyfriend at the moment
brokenhearted clayton leaves the
apartment soon after clayton leaves
she is attacked again by the person in
the gas mask ellen manages to dial 911
before she passes out as the attacker
pushes a syringe onto her neck
later the paramedic tells her that
there's no apparent injury and not a
needle mark on her neck
when detective bryce comes in he tells
her that the cctv also shows no one
enters the apartment after clayton
after hearing that ellen feels
distressed she can no longer believe her
own perceptions
feeling isolated from everyone in her
life and believing someone is after her
ellen decides to end her own life and
that is when we jump back to the
beginning
and watch as she writes a suicide note
and then climbs up onto the balcony
railing and jumps off
however instead of dying ellen falls six
feet and is just fine
she quickly discovers that she's in a
soundproof room
a room without a door a room with
speakers that played the sounds of the
city
a fictional city and a fictional
high-rise she quickly realizes the
apartment she was staying in was fake
and all of the noises outside were
coming from a speaker system
she hears the 11 am car alarm go off and
climbs back into
the apartment after climbing back into
her apartment she explores the hallway
only to find she cannot escape
so she heads out and knocks on lana's
door and lana tells her that this is
home
that there is no leaving clayton then
arrives to cook ellen's dinner
when they sit down to eat dinner ellen
hears clayton knock on the table twice
ellen recognizes this double tap knock
and realizes that everybody else she's
interacted with since the attack has the
same knocking
that's when she realizes everyone she's
met since she woke up in the hospital
the nurse the doctor the police
detective the paramedic
lana's husband were all clayton
realizing this truth
she pretends to drop her drink and hits
him on the head with a knife block
she immediately takes his key in a taser
and escapes down the hallway into the
apartment next door
however it is actually a weird empty
storage area
where clayton keeps all his costumes and
everything else he needed to pull off
this ruse
clinton has been using various disguises
to play everyone
even more surprising ellen finds her
assailants outfit
which reveals that clayton was the one
who attacked ellen to make her blind
and took her directly to this fake
apartment to keep her captive
she then finds lana who is actually real
in a hidden room
this room is the fake hospital room she
was brought to at the beginning of the
film
she reveals she is clayton's sister and
she helped him kidnap ellen
she then tells ellen their only hope of
escape is by using the hidden vent in
clayton's room
as ellen is trying to escape clayton
catches up to her
knocks her out and drags her into his
room it's the room that lana had
previously mentioned contains the only
way out through a vent in the wall
ellen feels the air from the vent and
realizes that she has yet another chance
to escape
clayton launches into a monologue
explaining his actions
when he was a kid his father had locked
him and his sister
lana up in the basement holding them
captive for three years after their
mother had died
the only way clayton had survived was by
making up characters in his head
giving them backstories and pretending
to be them but what had truly saved him
was the music that lana played for them
in the attic
the music he heard was ellen's who was a
child prodigy violin player
he refers to her as his light in the
dark so now
he wanted to be the same for her as he
relays his story and motives
ellen grabs a chance to decapacitate him
with a taser and opens the vent
but discovers that it's too small for
her to crawl through
taped inside the vent ellen finds a
small vial of the same substance that
had blinded her
when clayton comes around again she
sprays the substance in his eyes
effectively blinding him too as clayton
rides in pain
lana arrives on the scene upon seeing
clayton disabled
she frees ellen sending her out into the
real world
six months later allen prepares to go on
stage to the sound of an elated crowd
and that's how the movie ends now for
the explanation
when watching this movie we may notice
that ellen is in every single scene from
the very beginning to the very end
the reason for this is that this entire
film is told from ellen's perspective
everything we see in this film is what
ellen assumes is there we see what ellen
thinks she would be seeing
the only things we can trust as viewers
is what ellen hears
and what ellen touches this is best
signified by the bird at the beginning
which changes from green to blue as
clayton describes to ellen that the bird
is blue
if ellen thinks the bird is blue we see
the bird is blue
this is why when anyone shows up in
front of ellen we always see the person
that ellen assumes the person is
but once the person speaks or once ellen
touches them we realize who they
actually are
because ellen is realizing who they
actually are and this perspective is
used throughout the entire film
as we also see in the movie ellen has
been trying to contact her best friend
but she hasn't been picking up or
returning her calls this is because
clayton has disconnected her from the
outside world ellen's friends and family
had no idea she was missing
no one had any clue where she was or
what she was going through
as the movie comes to a close clayton
explains to ellen
he wants to be the light in the darkness
for ellen here
we can assume he blinded ellen in hopes
that she would be so helpless that she
would need him
in this way his character resembles
someone with munchausen by proxy
which is a mental health problem in
which a caregiver makes up or causes an
illness or injury in a person under his
care
clayton also explained to ellen he would
also create various personalities while
in the attic to have his own imaginary
friends
he uses the talent he learned in the
attic of playing multiple characters
to fool ellen into believing she is
interacting with multiple characters
he even imitates the voice of ellen's
brother
in the end the movie cuts to six months
later with ellen back playing the violin
on stage again
however it isn't entirely clear if she
has her sight or not
it could be that clayton wasn't lying
when he was pretending to be the doctor
who told her it was irreversible however
since he was even lying about the color
of the bird in her apartment
we might not even be able to trust him
about this and it's very possible she
was only temporarily blind
that's my explanation for the movie
siteless subscribe for more videos like
this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching